merci voilà c'est à toi peuple et qui
m'avait dit allez un petit peu bon quand
même
voilà en tout cas je sais pas où ils ont
séduites et oui merci c'est bon merci
une infusion l'échalote vous aimez pas
si si si vous préférez de sa non merci
je ne touche pas sa fumée la drogue nuit
à la santé mais c'est qui ce type qui
seul devant toulon
c'est un ancien du vietnam il a fait de
même non non il vivait au vietnam
d'accord là j'avais su ce qu'ils
faisaient là bas qu'il ait quelques
problèmes avec des mineurs et devinez de
quel âge par exemple 30 35 ans c'était
dans les mines de bauxite et puis il est
rentré en france il a repris la ferme
familiale puis s'est mis a déraillé
quand il a perdu son cheptel en fête à
léo s'il avait un cheptel et où ben oui
parce que quand les types de la ddsv
duché volcan mais en fait ils ont abattu
non seulement son cheptel me l'ont
abattu tous les cheptels et ça
apparemment il n'a pas supporté que tu
vois c'est pour ça qu'il en voulait à sa
grand-mère au fait c'est pas à cause de
la baraque sa cause de ces cochons c'est
ça à cause des cochons en même temps
elle n'a pas tort notre grand mère était
persuadé que c'était lui qui avait buté
jean-françois [ __ ] tu vois j'étais sûr
que c'est un [ __ ] de serial killer ce
mec c'était qui jean-françois sempé
enchères qui s'appelait jean françois
d'accord nom original
elle a trouvé cloud à une porte un matin
dans un sale état
mais c'est évident mais c'est évident
que c'est ce mic est derrière tout ça
c'est sûr il a poussé à venir mais ce
calais pour se venger et maintenant ils
faire la même avec nous c'est évident
mais vous en fais pas je suis là
maintenant
ok c'est à dire bah quoi oublier pas dit